il se sacrifie ils sacrifient leur vie
pour sauver un laurent dubreuil aux
compagnons d'armes et les civils et au
cours de l'été concevable et non
militaire le mail f1 milices du données
passage se montre ' héroïque a dirigé la
brigade de fusiliers
motorisés numéro 100 est
particulièrement héroïque le colonel les
regarde dans l'ailé dans la région de
van la parra a réussi à percer un
plusieurs laurent de défenseurs que i
les nationalistes renforcer et
construisez dur pendant près de 8 ans
voir le commandant de l'unité de char à
1 victoire historique
détruire cinq chars le 25 février
touchant pachuca
commandant de la compagnie 165 le
capitaine alex o'loughlin notre analyste
s'est heurté à l'unité des nationalistes
qui comptait quinze chars
et plusieurs véhicules blindés aux
attaques ont
éliminé la totalité de ses équipements
et il a cure a remporté la victoire dans
ce combat il
a été
le héros et benzema gameiro gilenia de
magnet de malheureusement reçoit cette
distinction posthume ans il était fermé
en commandant ces troubles est unie et
il j'ai protégé du jour et ruminer ses
soldats de passeligne il a été gravement
blessée mais lacombe études qu'officier
jusqu'à la fin il empoche la gauche fait
ceux des animaux la grenade courant si
on a sacrifié et
tu es également l'ennemi car c'est le
combat contre les néo nazis
les russes vous savez je suis
profondément en russie ce rythme mais
quand je vois ces exemples héroïque
comment gadji magomedov race qui était
un
jeu du daghestan daguestan et je veux
dire que je suis gay ce temps je suis dj
am je suis russe je suis ta tard je suis
mort jean je suis aussi team
car il y avait plus de 300 groupes
ethniques en russie et je ne
sais pas je te quand même je serai les
énumérer tous à signer
un seul peuple un seul peuple puissance
de la russie mais je ne renoncerai
jamais à ma conviction que les russes et
les ukrainiens forment un seul et même
peuple même
si beaucoup d'habitants en ukraine en
eau subi cet asservissement et cette
propagande
de la part
des rares ou autres qui étaient du côté
de hitler pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale en est une autre un autre
combat contre les néo nazis éprouvé par
le déroulement dans une unité des
hostilités il y à des unités de néo
nazis et les mercenaires étrangers y
compris un dieu
proche orient il se protège avec des
boucliers humains j'ai déjà dit qu'il y
avait des données qui montrent qu'ils
placent aussi le matériel militaire
lourd disent tout et dans les villes
dans les zones habitées
c'est ce sont donc les bandits ou bref
au lieu de remplir leurs engagements et
de retirer leurs matériels de ces zones
habitées des hôpitaux
d'autres sites au contraire il ça on n'a
même plus les avantages un autre et en
plus c'est vrai en otage les citoyens
étrangers y compris des milliers de
jeunes étudiants qui
était étudiant en ukraine je suis
pendant plus de 24 heures il retenait à
la gare à calquer plus de 170 étudiants
indiens il continue à les détenir et
510 personnes
et les néo nazis ont tiré sur les
étudiants chinois qui essayait de
quitter car qui veut deux d'entre eux
ont été listés je voudrais répéter que
des centaines d'étrangers vous devez
quitter les zones de combat mais on ne
les laisse pas faire ils les prennent en
otage ou il leur propose d'aller via la
pologne c'est à dire de traverser la
totalité de la zone des combats ils ceux
qui mettraient leurs vies en péril nos
militaires ont proposé est fourni d un
couloir pour passer dans tous les autres
les zones de combat et même des
transports pour pouvoir évacuer les
étrangers en lieu sûr je tiens à
souligner une fois de plus ce sont les
nationalistes kurdes qui empêche de le
faire et un brushing mêmes avantages et
ils disent aux étrangers de s'adresser à
leurs autorités de leur pays qui devrait
s'adresser au ministère des affaires
étrangères ukrainien boxer n'est en
arctique chanson juste laissé sur le feu
et les néo nazis se comportant de
manière encore et je veux dire avec
leurs propres citoyens chez les
utilisent comme boucliers humains non
mais les pères voit que dans des villes
les républiques populaires de deux bases
assainies ainsi que les soutiens ces
autres
il y a même jeu des habitants qui sont
placés prosterner à un étage
intermédiaire tandis que sous leurs
pieds à au rez-de-chaussée les matériels
militaires
les canons sont placés et au dessus sur
le toit ya des snipers selon ces
machines se comporter de manière aussi
inhumaine quand elle est troupes
soviétiques les combattez et notamment
pour les lire et en libérant le
territoire ukrainien je continue je
confirme c'est non un militaire font
tout pour éviter les pertes humaines de
ses représentants je ne demanderai pas à
vaincre angers et malheureusement ils y
laissent leur vie parce que nous voulons
soutenir tous ceux qui ont combattu avec
nous
pour tous les militaires qui prennent
part à cette opération spéciale en
ukraine il y aura des versements de 7
millions j'ai 2 121 mille roubles
l'udinese l'église il y aura une
compensation mensuelle main pour la
famille chaque soldat de pop tombés au
combat et je considère qu'il faudrait
ici à voir
inversement pour les membres 1 à 2 tous
ceux qui ont participé les membres de
familles de tous ceux qui ont participé
il s'agit d'une enveloppe de cinq
millions de roubles et tous les blessés
auront également fournir du nord est
mignon versement vernier d'assurance et
j'ai pas mal hésité
six militaires
professionnels ne peut plus continuer
son contrat il recevra 2 millions qu'une
moins 1 600 mille roubles s'il est
la capacité navale citée est constatée
il y aura des versements mensuels
je considère qu'il faudrait prévoir
aussi des versements supplémentaires aux
militaires de la défense et d'autres
unités des forces
qui ont été blessés jusqu'à 3 millions
de roubles
je
sais que nos soldats nos fils yep
combattent sur le territoire ukrainien
pour la russie pour la vie pour les
instances de base pour la dénazification
qu'on est démilitarisation pour qu'au
film anti russie donc créé par
l'occident depuis des années à nos
frontières ne puisse nous menacent et
notamment les armes nucléaires comme
c'était le cas dernièrement notre peuple
est fier de nos forces armées et nous
allons toujours nous garder en mémoire à
fives non vie compagnons d'armes qui
sont morts nous ferons tout pour se
tenir leurs enfants leurs familles pour
que leurs enfants puissent faire leurs
études ou se tiendront à leurs proches
je vous demande de rendre hommage à part
cette minute de silence à tous ceux qui
sont tombés en ukraine lors de cette
opération militaire spéciale
je vous en prie
je foutrais
l'opération militaire spéciale se
déroule comme prévu
pour un jeu les objectifs prévus il
tombe des objectifs prévus sont atteints
avec succès et dans les délais prévus
je donne la parole aux représentants du
ministère de la défense sergei kuta
beach
voilà vous venez d'entendre vladimir
poutine le président russe s'exprimer
sur la guerre en ukraine guerre qui a
débuté il y a une semaine maintenant
elena volochine bonsoir vous êtes
correspondante pour france 24 vous êtes
dans le pays depuis dix ans ont besoin
d'entendre vladimir poutine le président
russe qui a à nouveau parler de
dénazification de l'ukraine il parle
d'opération militaire spéciale il
n'utilise pas le mot guerre encore une
fois
vadimir poutine qui estime que tout se
déroule comme prévu mais il voulait
devenir poutine qui on le rappelle à
interdire à tout le monde d'utiliser le
mot guerre en russie y compris aux
médias on doit parler de cette opération
militaire spéciale alors moi ce que je
vois là dans son intervention c'est un
besoin une nécessité de justifier le
fait que la russie est dans une
opération militaire et subi des pertes
parce que là on voit de plus en plus
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux de
messages de témoignages de gens qui ont
perdu leur fils lors leur mari
beaucoup de choses qui commencent à
circuler sur les pertes que subit la
russie donc il fallait là que vladimir
poutine s'exprime officiellement l'armée
russe annoncer 498 mort on sait que dans
ce genre de situation les chiffres ont
tendance à être être revu largement à la
baisse donc d'abord il est dans son
exercice classique dans ce genre de
situation pas dans ce genre de situation
parce qu'il est inédite mais de façon
générale lorsque il y à une catastrophe
un attentat ou quoi que ce soit la
première chose qu'il fait c'est il
annonce des enveloppes pour les familles
donc là il a annoncé cinq millions de
roubles pour les morts 3 millions de
roubles pour les blessés donc là il a
besoin de travailler au niveau 2 pignon
public un clairement et il a évidemment
justifier le fait que la russie était
dans le dans le bon rôle un rôle de
défense donc il a dit effectivement pour
la dénazification la démilitarisation
pour les habitants du dombass pour
contrer la menace anti russe et aussi il
a de nouveau brandon on va ré coûté
vladimir poutine qui continue à
s'exprimer le président russe a
rencontré l'unité de nationalistes qui
comprenait 15 chars et six véhicules
blindés
le capitaine birkin et ses hommes à
chevaux pour nous détruire tous les
véhicules un boîtier blindé cinq chars
un sens
pour tenir son côté
et j'ai signé des ordres pour gagner du
récit ou gênants chef magomedov
pour la distinction héros de russie
posthume en malheureusement il
commandait aux mains de ses hommes dans
le combat de manière ferme et héroïque
il défend l'idée de passer ces soldats
et même en étant grandement blessés
combattez jusqu'à la fin ils les ont
fait exploser un pur utilisé lui-même et
les
amis autour car ce sont les néo nazis
qui autrement en torturant les
prisonniers et les tubes moi je suis n 2
mois est profondément russes n'ont pas
lésiné ne l'a pas courir est que les
russes car j'aime mais quand je vois un
combattant comme
rarement magomedov qui il ya du
daguestan et notre ethnie et d'autres
non millière je veux dire je suis de
cette ethnie l'accusé de glisse d'amener
était russe est juif et mourinho sexy et
plus de 60 groupes ethniques
en russie et je pense que vous me
comprenez le juge très large de les tuer
et je suis fier de faire partie s'ils de
ce nom de ce peuple impuissant qui le
peuple russe leur jeu le gérant des
lignées et en même temps je ne
renoncerai jamais à la conduction que
les russes et les ukrainiens forment un
seul et même pas de blagues et malgré le
fait que beaucoup d'ukrainiens en est et
écervelée par la propagande nationaliste
ont été intimidés certes inconsciemment
ont suivi la voie des négociales east
les partisans de bandeira ce qui était
du côté de hitler pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale et le fait que nous
combattons les néo nazis on assiste
éprouvé par le déroulement du destin des
hostilités
unités un néonazi
nationalistes et les mercenaires
étrangers compris du proche-orient
l'utilisent des civils en tant que
bouclier humain un jour il y a des
photos qui montrent comment il place le
matériel militaire lourd on dans les
centres villes et qui mme aubry et ils
agissent sans renier bendit comme des
bandits et des
hauts lieux de remplir leurs promesses
de retirer ce matériel lourd il est
quartiers résidentiels
dr il ya un an plus tôt et d'autres
installations civiles au contraire il se
place plus d'afficher des rides des
mortiers des chars ils ont même pris en
otage les citoyens étrangers et fait des
milliers de jeunes et étudiants
étrangers qui suivent leurs études hors
frais en ukraine juste pendant plus de
24 heures trois mille bougies
samedi qu'il était retenu alliés
étudiants
il y avait aussi ceux qui étaient
al-karkhi 20 et qu'ils nous préparent
quitter cette année l'essai il y as
descente